animated gifts have been around for a
very long time we're talking like early
days of mass use of the web so we're
talking Geocities mid-90s technology
here and yet they're still popular
they're still on every damned BuzzFeed
article and every tumblr there is and
the reason is because they work pretty
much everywhere and they're also a
really good example of the trade-off
between space and time or between memory
and time in computing animated gifts
have been around so long that they're
actually a verb now officially
recognized gif or Jif if you want to
pronounce it the official way that's
blatantly wrong you can find that one
out in the comments uh-huh they are a
really inefficient way of storing video
because gif wasn't designed as a format
for storing what it's used for now like
actual video clips it was used for
simple animations and you can see that
in the restrictions that it has the
whole gamut of colors that you can use
on the web is actually the cube of the
number of colors you can using a gif so
gif will let you have 256 colors the web
256 values for red for green and for
blue multiply those you get 16,777,216
colors that's how many you find in a
photo the gif will only let you have 256
which is where you get that kind of
weird compressed grainy effect more than
that the colors don't change for each
frame again with rare exceptions using
really advanced gif makers but generally
one palette for every frame so if you go
from a beautiful sunset with all those
gorgeous yellows in it and then go to
the ocean with lots of Blues you're
gonna run out of colors very very
quickly the other restriction with gifts
is frame rate this video you're watching
will be either 25 or 30 frames a second
I don't know which one you're using
gifts generally don't go above 20 and
rare to see anything above 10 or 15
which is why you get that slightly shaky
effect from the kind of judge area
effect you see and a lot of gifts the
reason for that is they were designed
for animation not for video
I mean gif is wonderful if what you want
to compress are simple line drawings if
you want to go beyond that not really
good reason for that is that gif uses
well very limited interframe compression
there are two types of compression you
can use in video there is interframe
compression which is what most modern
formats use and there is intra frame
compression which is what gif mainly
uses and these ones inter and intra
you'll have heard before for like
intergalactic space where you have the
space between galaxies and intra
galactic which is just the space within
one galaxy and it's an important
distinction because interframe
compression is how all modern video
formats work even back to the early MPEG
ones in the you know that were being
used at the same time as gif was coming
out mpeg-2 which is what DVDs use and
mp4 which is almost certainly what
you're watching right now they all use
interframe compression and the idea is
this you get the first picture which is
like regular photo compression it's
crushed down little and then that
picture isn't stored for about 25 frames
more until there's a major change until
then it just tracks the differences so
if I stay perfectly still as still as I
can then all that the MPEG compression
will do pretty much is my mouth the rest
of me there'll be harder need eighty
compression there at all because well
hopefully the rest of me isn't moving I
mean behind if I start flailing about a
lot like this then suddenly yeah if you
move the camera as well suddenly
everything here is having to move it's
having to work a lot harder and what
it's doing instead of changing every
frame sort of storing every single frame
it's saying right in here that big block
of pixels that's red that's that t-shirt
that's moved a bit that way and zoomed
out of it and this pinkish block here
that's for ham that's move that way a
bit and the fingers moved so it works
out the differences between each frame
and occasionally it will store the
entire image if that's more efficient
particularly on a quick change of you
suddenly zoom thank you
then it will often go to a new keyframe
those it's called but generally it will
just track the differences between gif
isn't designed to do that we're talking
mid 90s here maybe it was possible to
have a video stream going but at the
same time as you're trying to display a
webpage
at the same time as he tried to track
everything else going on in the system
no he couldn't do that so gif was
designed with mostly just intraframe
compression intra frame compression is
like storing a series of photographs
each one is pretty much independent from
the one before and the one after now you
can see why this is less efficient
you've got enormous space savings if you
say that wall doesn't change at all it
has limited interframe compression if
nothing has changed in a pixel you can
just set it as transparent and the one
from the previous frame will sort of
show through but other than that if
something changes you have to encode it
completely all over again and this is
one of the basic trade-offs of computer
science because in exchange for the
extra file size the extra data that
you're storing it is a lot easier to
decompress instead of having to worry
about storing one frame another and then
managing the differences between and all
the little fiddly things that you have
to do there you just show a picture and
then you show another picture and then
another simple as that gif in exchange
for that extra file size that that poor
compression is actually really really
easy I mean back in the Geocities days
you could have you know flaming skulls
rotating on your webpage an entire
background of flames as as many
Geocities sites including mine might
well of done I've just realized there
are people watching this who aren't
gonna remember Geocities because they
were born after it which is really weird
Geocities was so bad so it was the
myspace of its day but no it was the
tumblr of its day uh-hum they gave you
free web space and you wrote up the HTML
code yourself you uploaded it and it was
wonderful and then it was bought by
Yahoo and it was not wonderful anymore
anyway you see this trade-off everywhere
in computer science if you have an app
that has do a really complicated
calculation it might take a few seconds
you can either let it do that
calculation each time just send the
formula to do that calculation off to
the app so user types in whatever number
they need the hitter button it does the
calculation three seconds later the
response comes back to them or you can
make the app much much bigger you could
include
result for every number they could
possibly type in pre-calculated just
calculated once beforehand and instead
of sending them a formula you send them
a lookup table it might be megabytes or
gigabytes in size but instead of having
to do that calculation you trade off the
time for the space and instead of three
seconds you waste 500 megabytes as there
are between numbers I pulled from
anywhere but the trade-off is that the
trade-off is there in cryptography I've
mentioned rainbow tables before rainbow
tables which trade-off computation time
for hard drive space so rather than
having to calculate millions and
millions of hashes for this one password
someone has already done it for you so
you can spend days or weeks or months or
years or millennia brute forcing a
password or you can use megabytes or
gigabytes or terabytes of data to try
and jump forward in the calculation I'm
summarizing here and cryptography nuts
will be extremely angry at me for doing
that but essentially it's the same trade
off rather than processor time you trade
off for space it's one of the
fundamental principles of computer
science and it's best explained with
animated gifts
the thing about gifts is it's one of
those weird things where the medium
defines the message like movies have to
be between about 90 minutes and three
hours depending on the genre vines have
to be six seconds well six and a half
seconds actually this one was determined
by technology by what bandwidth could
support by what the file size was
acceptable and it's interesting to see
something where it's not been decreed
it's not been agreed overtime either
it's just whatever happens to fit into
the technology